I'll deal with the quarterback real
quick
concerned with his Achilles MRI is
probably going to confirm what we think
is already going to happen so prayers
tonight but it's not good
coach
what did you learn about this team that
maybe you didn't know prior to the game
uh
personally didn't learn anything uh I
think we all know what we have in that
locker room I think
we'll continue to keep speaking with the
way we play and uh and I think that's
what those guys are they're an
unbelievable resilient group we've
already known that our defense came out
in the second half and just took it
personal
uh take the ball away from those guys
four times stop after stop after stop I
thought offense was absolutely uh
speaking the right language at halftime
uh came out of the locker room made the
adjustments we needed to make and got
the points we needed to get and uh so
just overall I just thought it was an
unbelievable game all the way across the
board special teams obviously obviously
capping it off but uh proud of the group
but they didn't
that we don't already know in the locker
room
how do you process your emotions right
now just a great win for you guys but
the iron injury uh
that part sucks I'm gonna enjoy this win
winning in the NFL is hard regardless of
who the quarterback is
um personally I don't hurt for me I
don't hurt for our locker room I heard
for Aaron and how much he's invested in
all of this
um you know so I'm still going to say a
prayer I'm still going to hold that hope
but uh you know my my hearts are there
and right now and nowhere else